[Applaudissements]
bertrand d'argent mer cimer craint
d'être là c'est toujours un bonheur de
vous retrouver les 10 ans de mariage de
kate et william
alors à la question que vous pose est ce
qu'on se pose tous est ce vraiment un
couple modèle kate et william ça fait
dix ans maintenant mais ça passe à une
vitesse mais c'est la dette à dix ans
c'est fou ça y'a plus de saison
ils se sont mariés le 29 avril 2011
quand ils se rencontrent et déjà kate et
william 2001 septembre 2001 à s'attendre
où on est en huile et commence ses
études supérieures en quelque sorte
et à l'heure toutes les jeunes filles
vous savez du royaume uni vont
s'inscrire en écosse également à
saint-andrew en espérant pouvoir croiser
la route à saint louis qui sera un jour
et kate c'était son but aussi de la
disant qu'elles étaient inscrits avants
william
on a consulté les archives donc on sympa
vraiment dire que c'était fort c'est là
en tout cas on sait que carole middleton
qui est la maman de kate va beaucoup à
vrai puisque sa fille d'ailleurs dans le
but que kate et william puisse se
rencontrer est vraiment voilà d'accord
donc c'est donc n'hésitez pas voilà où
on ne peut pas la soupçonner veut dire
qu'on avait tout fait pour rencontrer
non non mais elle va tout faire en tout
cas pour être remarqués par williams
puisque quelques mots on entre et bahia
un défilé de mode femme et on demande
aux plus jolies jeunes filles de se
présenter pour défiler dans des
créations et kate doit porter une petite
robe noire assez sympa et elle décident
au dernier moment de retirer la robe et
de noeuds défilé en somme car et qui
induisent est mécanisé danse par le
dessous de la robe uniquement et william
qui est au premier rang la remarque
directement dans la barre oui les gars
jours après halle a lieu le premier
chien à qui ça je ne savais pas du tout
ça il a bien pris sa salle à elle a fait
craquer way
oui non essayez le king quoi qu est-ce
qu à lisser les marseillais à buckingham
alors c'est très bien ce qu'elle a fait
leur mariage c'est vraiment le mariage
du siècle
c'est le match du siècle précédent
mariage et sexe était charles et diana
absolument il ya eu 2 milliards dont
d'autres téléspectateurs tout visionnés
à des cérémonies de la recette 100
millions très exactement étaient 34
millions de dollars.le marianne ah oui
et la fameuse robe 350000 euros ou à la
robe de kate à 350 milles au sein des
pro ben m'hidi paris iii avec de la
dentelle de chantilly et de caudry on
peut peut-être fallu et ça c'est quand
même une partie des nations fox et 1900
c'est le nombre d'invités qui avait au
mariage gay ah ouais c'est mieux qu'à la
bar mitsva de gilles bensimon
il y avait quelques stars y avait david
beckham elton john yade et guy ritchie
avait mr bean oui absolument
quarante têtes couronnées ce qui est
quand même assez exceptionnel vous
imaginez la sécurité parce qu ils ont
fabriqué 3 5 millions parce ça a boosté
l'économie anglaise et voile à
l'alliance tdk même série le connemara
vient d'ailleurs dix ans jour pour jour
lors de l'incroyable collection dont qui
est vraiment l'institution qui gère les
produits dérivés
hélas que j'étais à londres jour du
mariage dont j'ai pu l'acheter
directement attaque au sein même de nos
cinq gammes sait combien ça je ne sais
plus mais c'est pas donné mais c'est pas
mon salaire fallait rembourser le
mariage ça va comment comment se
rapporte aux couples ce genre de truc à
ccc
c'est énorme c'est énorme c'est à dire
ne pas dire que on estime qu'un mariage
princier ne coûte absolument rien
malgré la somme astronomique qui doit
être des bourses r les caisses sont
entièrement rempli si l'on peut dire par
les retombées économiques de vente de
produits et d'image il faut quand même 2
milliards 500 millions de
téléspectateurs ça fait vraiment une
manne d'argent en matière d'image
puisqu'on estime que dans les années qui
viennent le le tourisme va être
considérablement relancer ça il faut s
qui sont vraiment très amoureux ou pas
ou c'est du mytho kate et william ouais
ils sont très amoureux
oui son trait à monsieur ou même si même
si même si de la part de william
il est vrai il ya eu quelques petits un
carton jaune
il est gros temps d'attenté c'est que
cette histoire
bah oui oui il est vide à lloret oui ce
n'est d'ailleurs crise donc en effet
2015 tout d'abord qui les ont libérés ce
cas mais je peux pas tout mais bon c'est
quoi à deux reprises il aurait pété me
tiens ça me voyais pas ça inclut une
mannequin australienne touila bord et
puis alors surtout 2017 2018 elle est
enceinte de son troisième enfant le
prince louis et là en effet il se
rapproche vraiment d'une aristocrate
anglaise la très haute aristocratie
c'était qu'il s'agit donc d'une certaine
rose de son prénom elle est issue de la
très haute aristocratie puisque son mari
et marty très proches depuis toujours de
la famille royale
il doit elle a trompé son mari a marqué
l effet comme julien mariller absolument
et oui voilà à plusieurs reprises il se
serait vu et il y aurait eu quand même
pas l'aide au logement alors kate kate
n'a absolument rien dit avoir réagi
il ya du tout mais ce que vous ne croyez
pas que kate est elle au magazine un
magazine à un moment où ça va exploser
subtil très maligne elle n'est pas à
l'instar d'autres grandes figures de la
saga windsor elle elle est ambitieuse
qui est payante à part des mois et donc
elle laisse passer
elle savait en se mariant avec william
kate qui l'a dit avec il avait les yeux
baladeurs et la cymbale away frais voilà
il n'a pas l'air du tout comme ça c'est
vrai on lui donnerait avec eux de ce
point de vue là à free est beaucoup plus
fidèle non c'est vrai oui serait rien
contraire de sa mère alors que williams
a vraiment hérité du gène des windsor
qui charles de charles entre au tchad
charlie pareil que c'est un chaud lapin
ce fut la raison il n'y a pas qu'à deux
reprises
c'est vrai qu'il a il a hérité de wade
vous voulez réagir là-dessus parce que
vous avez une info elle a quand même
réagi kate visiblement parce qu'à lui a
demandé de couper tous les ponts avec
rose énorme hazib le mans on l'appelait
ensuite à lui à lui aurait fait vivre un
cauchemar
et on l'appelait l'exterminateur en chef
un ah ouais faut pas vous dire mais
lorsqu'on est dans la campagne anglaise
qu'on a aucun titre de noblesse pas une
famille sans une goutte de sang bleu
dans les veines et qu'on devient un jour
la future reine d'angleterre croyez moi
il faudrait une détermination sa quête à
cette détermination là depuis toujours
lorsqu'elle était petite
avec sa soeur pippa que le monde entier
connaît madore ou les labels à sa règle
ici est la mecque ou pas pourra varier
qui monte qui monte là qui sinon qu'elle
a toujours été très ambitieuse a well as
et intelligent cela à la veille d'une
dylan à elle va pas faire de scène à
william hague accord elle a juste dit
désormais on ne la verra plus c'est ça
comme l armada avec plein d'autres
courtisans qui était dans le cercle de
william wesley de la dinde au pied de
kate middleton pourquoi ses parents et
sa mère était hôtesse de l'air lorsque
kate arriver quelque part
l'ecopad eaton de wiljan imite la voix
d'une hôtesse de l'air en mettant en
quête y est annoncée voit trois pistoles
et n'a jamais rien dit elle n'a jamais
réagi
voilà donc un jour à cette tâche à
rideaux ou flaubert
est-ce que vous avez des petites
anecdotes sur leur couple sur le coup
c'est william on peut surtout dire en
matière d'anecdotes à des petites
anecdotes c'est surtout un couple qui
travaille il bosse en permanence à wes a
vraiment lu ciment dix enfants comme
travail cela
[Rires]
ils représentent ils avaient deux de
plus en plus d'accords dont qui sont
point je fais pas il assista mais ce
qu'ils arrêtaient de lave à plat de à
plein d'engagement
il parraine des dizaines d'associations
vous assure que c'est pas un job de
tours il ya une rivalité entre les deux
frères et des deux est des deux autres
mégane et kate
il n'y avait jamais eu avant la sphère
du m'excite là il est vrai qu
apparemment il y aurait eu un genre de
guerre at-elle aussi entre kate et
mégane notamment au moment du mariage de
harry et mégane 2 jours avant la
cérémonie lui aurait vraiment eu crêpage
de chignon c'est quoi déjà keïta bon jet
elle était après ses études en histoire
de l'art elle a travaillé
essentiellement dans la boutique de ses
parents puisque ses parents ont créé une
société ils sont pas nés riche du tout
d'accord ils ont créé cette drôle c'est
anecdotique aussi une société de farces
et attrapes pour les goûters
d'anniversaire des enfants et leur grand
succès en quelque sorte des basses et le
briquet il sape le coussin péteur qui
les a rendus très riche bref quand kate
middleton ce qu'il tenait d'un bon
milieu mais pas non plus excessivement
reste ce sont des gens nouveaux riches
comme on l'a vu lors elle a dit quand
même au prince mes parents ils sont
notre coussin péteur ces crèmes il a dit
quoi moi merci à toi mon père était dans
le coussin péteur et vous confirmer que
c'a été très populaires au royaume uni
alors oui absolument gros ce que
beaucoup pensent que megan mais megan
est très populaire en amérique dette est
vraiment une icône des anglais et des
anglaises il suffit qu'elle porte une
robe et je vous assure que dès le
lendemain c'est sans rupture de cette
association vous êtes vous dit megan est
populaire en amérique quand on lit les
tabloïds américains elle est détesté par
une bonne partie de la mairie à
l'oscillation qui prend la cause de kate
kate en disant ça c'est une vraie femme
alors que megan est une petite capsule
verdez est ce que kate elle est pas
vraiment marketing c'est à dire fais
semblant dessins et des robes est ce
qu'elle est sincère voilà des robes qui
valent pas grand chose pour que les gens
se reconnaissent en elle
dès qu'on attaque son image boom
elle traîne en justice les journaux est
ce que est ce que c'est pas une
fabrication kite mais est ce que dans le
fond elizabeth ii n'est pas très
marketing est ce qu'on aurait pu
m'aligner de la reine on leur demande
vraiment un étang produits windsor et ça
m a très bien pris à la veille d'une
meghan markle qui n'a pas compris la
chose qui a dit je prends les avantages
ans maria l'arrêt millions de lits et
puis je me barre moi je tourne comme
officiel parfaitement bien son héros et
caramel et [ __ ] tout le temps dès
qu'elle sort le choc à la salle
pourquoi sortir sa nouvelle et non moi
je croyais qu'elle est sûre et on peut
aussi singulièrement elle met des
couturiers français a le nord elle
s'habille aussi avec des couturiers
français et à leur petite anecdote tout
petit je devrais peut-être consacré un
autre une autre pastilles à ce genre de
choses c'est que bientôt les middleton
donc à directement la famille royale va
faire rentrer aux sables son casting est
bien une française dans une puisque le
frère de kate james va bientôt épouser
une française alizée téchené oui ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]